- On va aller se balancer,
je pense, parce que c'est ce que
Joanie, elle aime le plus,
se balancer.
- Marie-Claude Sénécal
et sa fille Joanie sont comblées
par les installations
du parc St-Joseph.
MARIE-CLAUDE SÉNÉCAL
- Ici c'est vraiment le plus
beau, il y a jamais ça
nulle part au Québec.
C'est vraiment le plus
magnifique que j'ai vu,
puis on se promène beaucoup.
- Contrairement à d'autres
espaces verts, il n'y a pas
qu'un ou deux aménagements
adaptés. Même les jeux d'eau
et le bloc sanitaire
ont été pensés en ce sens.
- Ils ont meme prévu des tables
a manger avec lève-personnes
pour pouvoir sortir la personne
du fauteuil roulant,
faire le changement de couche
et remettre la personne
dans son fauteuil roulant.
- Ce sont elles,
les instigatrices du projet,
qui a permis la réalisation
de ce parc inclusif. En 2016,
Marie-Claude et sa fille
interpellaient le Conseil
d'arrondissement sur cet enjeu.
- On s'assoit ici, chacun de
notre côté, puis on se balance.
- L'actuelle mairesse de
Rivières-des-Prairies-Pointes-
aux-Trembles s'en souvient
très bien.
CAROLINE BOURGEOIS, mairesse
Rivière-des-Prairies-P.-A.-T.
- Elle ne pouvait pas se rendre
avec sa fille à un endroit
où sa fille pouvait s'amuser
en toute sécurité. Et ça je vous
dirait que quand vous entendez
un témoignage comme celui-là,
vous vous en rappelez longtemps.
Donc, c'est vraiment issu
de cette mobilisation, de ce cri
du coeur.
- En plus d'avoir répondu
à cette demande,
les responsables du projet
ont consulté les bénéficiaires
avant de procéder.
- Ils ont demandé : "Quelles
sont vos attentes? Quels sont
vos besoins? De quoi vous auriez
envie?" Autant pour les non-
voyants que pour les lourdement
handicapés, les
multihandicapés, puis ils ont
fait une surface qui s'adapte
à tous les types de clientèle.
- Le parc St-Joseph a donc été
aménagé selon les principes
de l'accessibilité universelle.
GÉRARD BEAUDET, prof., école
d'architecture de l'UdeM
- D'être soucieux des moindres
détails qui peuvent paraitre
un peu insignifiants pour
quelqu'un qui a tous ses moyens,
mais qui peuvent être
des embûches sérieuses
pour des gens qui ont certains
handicaps, par exemple.
- D'ailleurs, la clientèle
pour qui ces aménagements
constituent un enjeu
est de plus en plus nombreuse.
ELSA LAVIGNE, directrice-
générale de Altergo
- En 2013, 33 % des Québécois
déclaraient avoir une limitation
fonctionnelle, donc c'est
quand même une portion très
importante de la population.
- Le vieillissement de la
population y est pour quelque
chose aussi et un autre facteur
qui a beaucoup aidé,
c'est qu'on s'est rendu compte
que quand on accomode les gens
qui ont certains problèmes
ou les gens, bon, par exemple,
les enfants en bas âge,
on accomode tout le monde.
- Des aménagements qui sont donc
profitables pour l'ensemble
de la population. Un grand atout
pour les familles,
selon Marie-Claude.
- Il faut qu'un parent puisse
se dire : "Je m'en vais au parc
avec mes enfants et tous mes
enfants, incluant mon enfant
handicapé qui puisse s'amuser."
C'est ca qu'on veut!
(rires)
- Ici Julie Emond,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.